en octobre dernier aux draps vigilance
le réseau européen de surveillance des
traitements médicaux a publié un tableau
on voit la présence de 25000 rapport de
personne décédée peu de temps après
s'être vacciner comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer cette nouvelle a alimenté le
mouvement antivaccinal sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans les rues selon lequel
les vaccins sont avant tout dangereux
mais ce chiffre montre est il vraiment
que les vaccins sont dangereux
bon cette fois je ne vais pas faire
durer le suspense et je vais mettre à
l'écran un trending que j'avais publié
sur twitter il ya plus d'un an en bref
non le chiffre de 25 minutes n'a
absolument rien de surprenant c'est en
fait même légèrement moins que l'ordre
de grandeur que j'avais anticipé il ya
plus d'un an pourquoi donc et bien il ne
faut pas oublier que malheureusement il
ya beaucoup d'autres raisons de mourir
que le vaccin lui-même en fait chaque
année on estime qu'une personne sur 100
meur c'est ce qu'on appelle le taux de
mortalité il peut être aussi bien dus à
un cancer qu'un accident ou plus
probablement encore à un avc ou
simplement à la vieillesse mais donc du
coup en l'espace d'un mois soit deux
fois moins de temps il ya environ une
personne sur 1000 qui malheureusement
moeurs maintenant réfléchissez un
intervalle d'un mois qui suit la
vaccination d'un individu quelconque
prix dans l'ensemble des personnes
vaccinées même si la vaccination n'avait
absolument aucun effet pendant ce mois
qui suit la vaccination il y à bien une
chance sur cent que la personne en
question meurt mais alors sur les 200
millions de vaccinés en europe on
s'attend à ce qu'une personne sur 100
meur un mois après la vaccination
bon effectivement il faudrait multiplier
par le nombre de doses reçues mais
restons à un sur mille pour simplifier
voilà qui fait déjà deux cent mille
personnes qui en 2021 sont mortes moins
d'un mois après s'être vacciner et alors
on peut imaginer que dans beaucoup de
cas la mort est clairement attribuable à
une cause autre que la vaccination est
que beaucoup de cas ne sont pas
rapportés à hydra vigilance mais alors
parmi beaucoup de cas restants la
famille a vu l'un des siens se faire
vacciner développer les effets
secondaires de la vaccination et mourir
dans le mois qui suit la vaccination dès
lors les familles déjà réticente au
moment de la vaccination vont sans doute
contacter audrey vigilance est signalé
une mort après vaccination
le fait qu'il y ait 25 mille de ces cas
n'a alors rien de surprenant
alors la vidéo
s'arrêter là mais j'ai quand même envie
d'insister sur la raison pour laquelle
le chiffre de 25 mille peut paraître
aussi trompeur à de nombreuses personnes
car cette statistique est loin d'être la
première à être trompeuses et c'est loin
d'être la dernière il est donc important
de développer de meilleurs réflexes pour
se prémunir de mauvaises interprétations
de tels chiffres mais bon j'aurais pu
aller dans plein de directions
différentes du biais de confirmation
raisonnement contrat factuelle qui
inviterait à comparer la proportion des
marchés est vaccinée à la proportion des
marchés les non vaccinés en passant par
le paradoxe de simpson qui conduit à
surévaluer le cas des personnes a priori
vulnérable mais le point sur lequel
j'aimerais insister aujourd'hui en
particulier c'est le problème du biais
de sélection et pour bien illustrer je
vais d'abord vous parlez du biais du
survivant vous avez sans doute déjà
entendu des célébrités comme steve jobs
parler de la source de leur succès par
exemple steve jobs a dit la chose
suivante je cite vous devez faire
confiance à ceux qui suivent votre
intuition votre destinée votre vie votre
karma et quoi que ce soit d'autre cette
approche ne m'a jamais trahie elle aura
fait toute la différence dans ma vie
bon j'ai envie de dire que l'intuition
de steve jobs aussi poussé à soigner son
cancer avec des médecines alternatives
et que ça ça pas très bien fini pour lui
non mais dans ça va deux côtés au moment
où il dit cette phrase l'intuition de
steve jobs semblait en effet lui avoir
permis de connaître un succès que très
peu de gens connaîtront dans leur vie ne
faut-il donc pas l'écouter si ça a
marché pour lui est ce que ça ne
marchera pas pour nous eh bien ce qu'il
faut bien voir c'est qu'il y a là un
biais de sélection énorme se concentrant
sur un individu unique on nommait tous
ceux qui comme lui ont fait confiance à
leur intuition mais qui contrairement à
steve jobs n'ont pas connu un succès
professionnel époustouflant après tout
la plupart des entrepreneurs se fit
probablement beaucoup à leur intuition
mais la plupart d'entre eux échouent
contrairement à steve jobs xkcd est
peut-être celui qui illustre le mieux ce
biais de sélection dans un dessin
intitulé sunrise chips bayonne on y voit
un vainqueur de l'autre y effectuer un
discours où il affirme que jouer à des
jeux d'argent encore et encore sans
relâche avec abnégation et persistance
ça finit par payer et le tout ne
surprend dans sa propre personne comme
exemple voient comme preuve sauf qu'il
faut bien voir que si cette personne a
été invité à prendre la parole c'est
parce qu'elle a à gagner à la loterie
autrement dit parmi l'ensemble des
joueurs d'argent la conférence a
sélectionné uniquement la personne qui a
gagné j'imagine que ce sera
particulièrement local si la conférence
est organisée par une entreprise de jeux
d'argent comme la française des jeux par
exemple bon bien sûr une conférence avec
une personne qui parle de l'abnégation à
jouer à des jeux d'argent c'est pas tout
à fait le plus standard en pratique bien
sûr la personne invitée est plus un
serial entrepreneur qui a fini par faire
fortune souvent d'ailleurs grâce à papa
et maman qui ont sans cesse remis un peu
de sous dans la machine un start up et
dans ce cas le phénomène reste bien le
même l'exemple de la personne invitée
est en fait très trompeur car il ya eu
un énorme biais de sélection des
organisateurs de la conférence qui ont
été invités cette personne qui a connu
le succès parmi tous ceux qui se sont
lancés un joueur dans l'expérience
entrepreneuriale
généralement le biais du survivant qui
consiste à mettre toute la lumière sur
un survivant ça va constituer un biais
de sélection énorme dès lors que
l'ensemble des survivants est un tout
petit ensemble de l'ensemble des
personnes qui ont fait ce que le
survivant déclare avoir fait et alors
dans le cas des vaccins se sont
davantage en fait les mots or qui sont
rares l'écrasante majorité des gens ne
sont pas mort du co vide qu'ils soient
vaccinés non vaccinés donc le simple
fait est de mettre toute la lumière sur
les morts c'est induire un énorme biais
de sélection autrement dit ça nous donne
une image très biaisée par rapport à
celles qu'on aurait si on contempler
tout le monde morts et vivants on a
ainsi le même problème quand on
s'attarde aux cas d admission en soins
critiques et qu'on oublie de regarder
l'ensemble de toute la population comme
illustre cette super image du site
lemonde et bien sûr on retrouve ce biais
de sélection bien au delà de la médecine
par exemple imaginons une émission tv
qui cherche constamment à organiser des
débats entre des positions opposées une
telle émission chercherait par exemple a
opposé un scientifique qui croient au
changement climatique un scientifique
qui le nie mais rien qu'en faisant cela
les missions crée nécessairement un
énorme biais de sélection car le
scientifique et timmy le changement
climatique n'est jamais pris au hasard
dans la population de l'ensemble des
scientifiques
bref il faut faire très attention
lorsqu'on a affaire à des données issues
du biais de sélection il ne faut surtout
pas prendre ces données comme argent
comptant or malheureusement ce biais est
absolument omniprésent surtout dans les
médias mais également dans les
publications scientifiques comme on a
déjà longuement parlé sur ce forum
et alors
trop présent c'est de se dire que si les
données sont biaisés alors on ne peut
rien en tirer est qu'il vaut mieux tout
jeter à la poubelle voir que ces données
et toute analyse de ces données ça ne
peut pas être scientifique est certes il
vaut mieux tout voté à la poubelle
plutôt que prendre ces données comme
argent comptant mais si on y réfléchit
bien même des données biaisées sont en
fait informative et même parfois très
informative imaginons par exemple une
entreprise qui sous prétexte de secret
professionnel et de protection de
données personnelles de leurs clients
refusent de partager leurs données et
leurs algorithmes avec qui que ce soit
et imaginons que notamment pour son
business l'entreprise a pourtant
effectué énormément de l'analyse en
interne de sa montagne de données et
supposons enfin que cette entreprise
soit très critiquée pour les activités
illégales et même pour être une menace
de sécurité nationale par exemple en
promouvant massivement les discours de
haine ils m'ont donné un nom à cette
entreprise disons non plus la
facebook ouanna étant poursuivis en
justice notamment disons pas ils ont des
victimes de génocides au hasard cette
entreprise a alors tout intérêt à
partager des données qui la protègent
mais imaginons que cette entreprise
souhaite alors incapable de fournir de
telles données et au lieu de ça prend la
parole pour dix ont annoncé un
changement de nom de son entreprise j'ai
envie de dire aux a fait un peu pas mal
et pour révéler un nouveau projet de
meta vert sur lequel l'entreprise
travaille et imaginons qu'au contraire
les rares documents qui ont liké de
cette entreprise montre au contraire que
l'entreprise est très dangereuse en fait
c'est pire que ça facebook a réagi olic
de ces données rendant beaucoup de ces
données internes inaccessible à la quasi
totalité de ses employés bon vous m'avez
vu venir même si je me suis lancé dans
la fiction ce dont je viens de parler
n'est absolument pas une je cite afin
d'éviter d'autres fuites les paramètres
d'accès interne aux discussions de
recherche de facebook sur des sujets
tels que la santé mentale et la
radicalisation ou été limité aux
personnes directement impliquées dans le
travail selon des employés et d'autres
personnes au courant de ces restrictions
les chercheurs de l'entreprise ont
déclaré qu'il aura avait été demandé de
soumettre des travaux sur des sujets
sensibles à l'examen des avocats de
l'entreprise qui ont parfois demander
des exemples de problèmes à supprimer
des messages internes
du groupe ne cesse de répéter mais aussi
horrible que les choses soient à fait
book chez google c'est en fait pire
l'équipier tic a été démantelée pour
être sûr qu aucune données internes
compromettantes ne pourra être liker et
pour s'assurer que les préoccupations
soulevées en interne sont littéralement
maltraités par les dirigeants de google
bref clairement facebook et google
effectue constamment un énorme biais de
sélection dans les informations qu'ils
choisissent de rendre publique est ce
pour autant qu'on ne peut rien et qu'on
ne doit rien inférées de ce qui a été
révélé
absolument pas si facebook disposer de
données solides qui montrait que des
mesures drastiques avaient été mises en
place pour lutter contre la
désinformation et les appels à la haine
et que ces mesures étaient très
efficaces alors facebook les aurait
clairement montré avec beaucoup de
fierté en fait on a là un cas ou en un
sens l'absence de preuves de sécurité
est une preuve de l'absence de sécurité
après tout facebook a beaucoup cherché
des preuves de sécurité et s'il en avait
trouvé il les aurait clairement partagés
et donc oui dans certains contextes
l'absence de preuve peut être tout à
fait une preuve de l'absence notamment
corse qui a eu énormément de recharge
qui aurait probablement déterrer des
preuves si ces preuves existent et
jacques les masques à un petit peu en
disant cela car elles sont de preuve
c'est une notion très mathématique qui
doit être restreinte aux mathématiques
ici il s'agit davantage de données très
convaincante en faveur de la sécurité or
les données sont toujours sujettes à du
bruit et des billets et donc ne peuvent
pas être aussi concluante que les
preuves mathématiques mais bon on peut
oublier ça aujourd'hui et le problème du
biais de sélection dont j'ai parlé ici
n'est bien sûr pas spécifique à facebook
en fait tous groupes militants va
inéluctablement cadrer la discussion
autour d'un sujet de sorte à mettre
toute la lumière sur quelques données de
leur choix et à ignorer l'ensemble de
toutes les données ou l'ensemble de
toutes les problématiques mais ça ne
veut pas dire que le choix de quelles
données révélées et la nature de ces
données doivent être ignorée ces données
restent informative pourvu que l'on
tienne suffisamment compte du biais de
sélection est quand même en prenant en
compte le biais de sélection les données
sont particulièrement compromettantes
comme par exemple au hasard dans le cas
des révélations de francesco gun contre
facebook il y a de quoi déplacer
radicalement notre curseur de crédence
mais bien sûr pour en arriver à de
telles conclusions il est critique de
bien analyser les données en question
ainsi que le biais de sélection qu'elles
ont subi bref bien analyser des données
sujette à des biais de sélection s'est
compliquée
je vais finir avec les cas
manière d'haïtiennes d'analysé des
données sujette à des normes biais de
sélection est le point clé le point
crucial le point qu'il faut absolument
avoir en tête c'est que pourra analyser
de telles données il faut modéliser le
biais de sélection malheureusement nous
avons tendance à sauter cette étape si
crucial et c'est pour cela que le
paradoxe les deux enfants en particulier
nous rend si fou j'en profite pour vous
encourager à voir ou à revoir cette
vidéo ce paradoxe des deux enfants c'est
vraiment mon paradoxe préférées d'une
part parce que je l'aurais mashaie sans
relâche pendant plus de cinq ans mais
d'autre part et surtout parce qu'il
contient en lui une énorme partie des
difficultés d'adopter un raisonnement
vraiment bayésiens en particulier pour
être un bon bayésiens il faut modéliser
le biais de sélection et ça ça demande
d'avoir un a priori avant d'analyser les
données sur la manière dont ces données
ont été générés et en particulier sur un
manière dont elles ont été biaisées par
un biais de sélection potentiel comme le
dit le proverbe bayésiens sans préjugés
aucune conclusion ne peut être tirée et
ça c'est d'autant plus le cas des
données observationnelles qui sont
constamment sujette à toutes sortes de
bières observationnelles mais du coup
nécessairement les conclusions qu'on
tirera dépendront inéluctablement de
notre préjugés sur le biais de sélection
qu'on subit les données c'est pour cela
que le balsa nisme est inéluctablement
subjectif il est sujet à nos données et
en particulier il dépend de ce qu'on
croit du biais de sélection qu'on subit
les données alors bien sûr en bon
bayésiens il faut envisager plusieurs
biais de sélection crédible qu'ont pu
subir les données tirer des conclusions
pour chacun des scénarios envisagés est
envisagé et où le multivers béliziens
démons probable sachant les données que
l'on a qui en résulte est bon faire tout
ça en pratique ça devient vite très
compliqué mais histoire d'être un peu
plus formel on peut typiquement imaginer
qu'il existe des données brutes des qui
ont été collectés mais qui lui un
traitement de ces données de sorte que
les données observées sont ensuite des
données aux qui sont une fonction f2 des
des données brutes et là de façon
critique pour appliquer la formule de
bayes il faut absolument tenir en compte
de la fonction de sélection f qui a
modifié les données brutes en données
observées au est en fait si vous écrivez
soigneusement les équations des
probabilités vous verrez que les lois
des probabilités vous impose de le faire
correctement en pratique bien sûr
effectué tous ses calculs et très
compliqué mais on peut les approximer en
faisant tout simplement l'effort
intellectuel de penser tout le flux des
données qui ont conduit à l'observation
de la donne est observée au en facebook
annonce meta qu'elles sont toutes les
histoires qui ont pu conduire facebook a
annoncé mme état et surtout lesquels
sont le plus crédible quand les
manifestations anti vaccinales met en
avant le chiffre de 25 mille vacciner
mort quelle est l'histoire derrière ce
chiffre comment ce chiffre a été
sélectionné parmi l'ensemble de toutes
les statistiques au sujet des vaccins
mieux encore oublié un instant que vous
connaissez ce chiffre et réfléchissez à
toutes les branches du multivers
bayésiens et à tous les chiffres que
vous pouvez imaginer avoir découvert
dans les branches parallèle du multivers
maintenant comparer les chiffres
auxquels il était raisonnable de
s'attendre avant de connaître le chiffre
qui est effectivement tombé êtes vous
alors surpris du chiffre qui est tombé
si avant de connaître ce chiffre vous
vous attendiez où vous vous attendriez à
ce que ces manifestations annonce un
chiffre beaucoup plus faible alors
d'après la formule de bayes en gros vous
devriez augmenter vos crédence ans la
dangerosité du vaccin mais si vous aviez
prédit un chiffre de cet ordre de
grandeur voire supérieure un an plus tôt
il n'y a alors pas de quoi augmenter vos
crédence la dangerosité du vaccin telle
manière badiane de raisonner avec les
données sujette aux biais de sélection
ce qui encore une fois représente en
fait quasiment toutes les données ok
vous savez accès